qui trônera sur le côté face de notre
monnaie quand elizabeth 2 va nous
quitter que vous admiriez la monarchie
ou que ce ne soit vraiment pas votre
tasse de thé sa majesté et votre chef
d'état est votre monnaie vous le
rappelle tous les jours après le décès
ou l'abdication de la reine la tradition
veut qu'on remplace son profil par celui
de non pollué par celui de son
successeur son fils charles le problème
c'est que le fils est moins populaire
que la mer en raison de son mariage
houleux qui a terni l'image de la
famille royale
supprimer le visage de la monarchie cela
exigerait l'unanimité et provinces du
sénat et de la chambre des communes
selon le journaliste marc laurendeau
c'est peu probable et l'éffigie de
charles devrait apparaître tôt ou tard
sur nos pièces il souligne toutefois
qu'une gouvernement à plus de liberté
avec le papier monnaie et que notre
allégeance évolué par exemple en faveur
de la diversité
reste que selon les sondages les
canadiens sont encore attachés à
elizabeth 2 le billet de 20 dollars en
témoigne l i à figurer pour la première
fois avant même d'être souveraine à
l'âge de huit ans et il se pourrait bien
qu'elle continue d'y régner même après
son départ du royaume des mortels
[Musique]